in 1989 an artist by the name of Dred
Scott who has also graced the Ted stage
created a piece of art in Chicago where
he simply placed an American flag on the
ground and then invited you the viewer
to go and stand on that flag in record
how it felt in a journal and to me one
of the most powerful things written in
that journal in essence says why are we
so ok with homeless people with human
beings laying on the ground but not
flags and some of you this piece of art
is quite disturbing and that's kind of
the point of this talk not to upset you
or to make you mad but to prove to you
that Flags have an incredible power and
that even if you think you don't care
about Flags you do you know you do all
right
by the end of it I hope that you're
inspired to go out and harness this
power of flags and fight for a better
world but before we get there we're
gonna start on the opposite end of the
spectrum before I show you the next
stuff I need to say that anything I show
here is not an endorsement it's usually
quite the opposite but more than
anything what I want to do is create a
space here where we can look at these
flags these designs and examine how they
make us feel we're going to talk about
our emotions is that okay with everybody
okay are you ready for your first flag
cool we'll start with an easy one
that was a joke
so some of you may be a little bit
uneasy sitting in a room with this I'm
certainly feeling uneasy standing in
front of it some of you may be feeling a
little bit of pride and that's
understandable this is Texas this is not
a rare sight is it but let's start with
the facts so this is not the Confederate
flag okay this is the battle flag of the
Army of Northern Virginia led by General
Robert Ely so next time someone tells
you that this is their heritage unless
their family fought for that very
specific militia they're wrong all right
and you have a flag experts permission
to tell them so this flag rose into
prominence during the mid 1950s and 60s
as a response to the growing civil
rights movement then of course today it
does come has come to represent the
Confederacy to most of us but I
shouldn't have to remind you what the
Confederacy is it was a rogue nation
that rose up against the United States
waged war on the US and at one point in
time this was one of the most unamerican
things you could have but yet this flag
is protected by the same laws that
protect the United States flag in the
states of Florida Georgia South Carolina
Mississippi and Louisiana but let's pick
on Georgia for a second shall we
so in 1956 a few years after
desegregation was mandated in public
schools Georgia changed their state flag
to this I think everyone watching can
agree that this was not meant to be a
flag that every Georgian was proud to
fly outside of their home was it no just
like all of the Confederate statues
erected in the mid 1950s and 60s this
was meant to be a symbol of who was in
charge and who was not this remained the
flag of Georgia until the year 2001 and
in that year they changed their flag to
this now as a flag expert I can tell you
this is officially ugly okay it's okay
to laugh at this flag it's ugly and
so ugly it that's one of the reasons
they changed it just two years later
they had a referendum where they got to
choose between that thing and then what
is now the current flag of Georgia now
some of you might be wondering wait a
second Michael if that before wasn't the
Confederate flag what was the
Confederate flag Georgia
flies the first flag of the Confederate
States of America to this day they just
slapped their state seal on it but let's
go back to our emotions for a second
that didn't punch you in the gut as much
as the other one did did it right and
that's why I love flex they are the
simplest pieces of design usually just
two or three colors just some bars or
stripes but yet they can invoke the
deepest emotions within us they'll make
us swell with pride or burn with hatred
we will die for a flag or even kill for
one one of my favorite designers his
name is Wally Holland's they call him
the father of nation branding and he's
quoted as saying that everyone wants to
belong and then they want to display
symbols of belonging and it's crazy that
these pieces of cloth that are just sewn
together or dyed come to be such a
sacred item and that's because they
become parts of our identity they are
powerful tools to unify but equally
powerful tools to divide you ready for
the next flag all right take a moment
really examine how you felt when this
hit the screen I'm gonna change the
slide pretty quickly so you don't take
pictures of me in front of this one all
right
so Germany after World War one it was in
a pretty bad state and a young Adolf
Hitler had a lot of let's call them
ideas of how Germany got to where they
got and then how to get them out as he
spent entire chapters in his book meine
Kampf which I don't recommend reading
about how Germany lost World War 1
partially because the British had better
graphic design and better propaganda and
so as the Nazi Party Rose Hitler created
one of the thickest brand guides I've
ever seen it's thicker than most company
brand guides today and in it he details
titles and uniforms and lots and lots of
flags Hitler knew the power of flags he
says in meine Kampf the new flag should
prove effective as a large poster
because in hundreds of thousands of
cases a really striking emblem may be
the first cause of awakening of interest
in a movement he was an artist after all
he knew the power of visual identity and
uniforms could reignite the German
identity and to millions of Germans this
was a welcome sign but of course this
was also a mark of death to others we
don't often think of flags as weapons
but like the Confederate battle flag the
Germans used their flag to make an
out-group feel unwelcome and less than
you see when you create a flag you
immediately do two things you create an
in-group a group that's meant to be
represented by the symbol but then
inevitably you create an out-group and
usually that's subtle it's a byproduct
it's usually not the intent but the
Germans were very clear as to who was
represented by the swastika and who is
not in 1935 Jewish people were banned
from flying German flags and in this way
the Germans may be marked more than any
other time in history used the dual
power of flags to unite but also to
divide flags are used as identity
weapons and now in 2019 the Nazi flag is
banned from being flown by anyone in
Germany and anyone in Austria and
Hungary in Russia and then Ukraine think
about that it's it's a piece of cloth
but it's banned on its face that sounds
crazy but I don't think anyone in this
room would disagree
that it's probably good it sounds a lot
like a weapon as a vexillology it's
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a flag is not so much its design
but it's those laws around the flag for
instance in India to create an Indian
flag you must use a hand spun cloth
named kadhi if you make a flag out of
anything else you could go to jail for
up to three years it's crazy here in
Texas we've all heard that the Texas
flag is the only state flag that can fly
the same height as the US flag right
because we were a nation before we were
a state who hears heard that yeah well
I'm here to tell you that is completely
false ok first of all we were not the
only state that was a nation before
joining up and secondly all state flags
can fly at the same height as the US
flag according to the US flag code and I
don't have to ask you how you feel about
this one right most of us grew up
pledging allegiance to this every
morning knowing we should never let it
touch the ground etc we take our flag
code very seriously here in the United
States you remember recently in some NFL
players kneeling during the national
anthem it was a big controversy they
were breaking the flag code it states
during the national anthem stand
attention hand over heart etc but what
was fascinating to me is the vexillology
astiz that I didn't see anyone getting
upset when something like this happens
the flag code says the flag should never
be carried flat or horizontally but
always aloft and free so sometimes
during the exact same national anthem
this was being done and no one's upset
or this this happens all the time the
flag code is cleared no part of flag
should ever be used as a costume or on
an athletic uniform this is Texas A&M
baseball not to get them in trouble but
this happens all the time especially in
November I'm sure I can almost guarantee
when you leave here tonight you will see
on the back of someone's car or truck a
black and white American flag with a
blue stripe a thin blue line
I blue lives matter that breaks the flag
code in multiple ways but all of these
things are done with the best intent
no one's here to argue that but of
course they break a section of the flag
code titled respect for the flag so by
putting this on your uniform you are
legally disrespecting the flag and what
I find interesting is that those NFL
players kneeling during the anthem and
the people who would put blue lives
matter stickers on their car are both on
the opposite end of a very big issue but
they're both breaking the exact same law
a law that is 100% unenforceable in fact
it was dred Scott's piece of art in 1989
that led the Supreme Court to rule that
the flag code is just a guideline you
cannot be prosecuted for breaking the
flag code you cannot be forced to be
patriotic so why then have all of these
little laws around how we use our flag
if you can't enforce them and that's
because a nation is a fragile collective
idea it only exists in our minds I see
this thank you
sometimes a flag is the only tangible
symbol of that idea right our unity is
sometimes only held together by literal
threats and that's powerful the flag
code is meant to preserve and protect
that fragile idea while also protecting
your right to break it and that's what's
special about the United States right
and that's what's unique about our flag
our flag is amazing it has changed more
than any other flag in the world it's
the flag code that says when a new state
is created a star shall be added to the
union of the flag and such addition
shall take place on the fourth day of
July our flag is unique because it is
meant to grow as we grow by design and
by law it is meant to change with us
it's a living
symbol of our individuality our
diversity and the stars in our unity we
have a gift in the United States to have
a flag that is inclusive
if the Nazi flag was an identity weapon
the United States flag by design alone
stands in direct contrast and I have to
say as a vexillology stin 2019 using
this flag as an identity weapon against
anyone disrespects it far more than
letting it touch the ground or any one
of the other little laws that we break
every day right this flag is a symbol of
our unity we should never use this as a
weapon against someone else I resonate
so deeply with the person who wrote and
read Scott's journal we should never
value the symbol over the thing that it
symbolizes we should never value a piece
of cloth over a human life and if you're
ever gonna use a piece of thought as a
weapon you should never use this one not
when it has always had room for more
stars hopefully by now you've felt the
power of flags and you can see what they
can do so what if we harness that power
and we used it to fight for something
greater this is the flag of Earth
designed by Oscar Poorna Feld of Sweden
just imagine with me for a second what
if we celebrated our humanity as much if
not more than we celebrate our
nationalities as we become a spacefaring
civilization and we go off into the
Stars what do our nation's mean anyway
when you're standing on the surface of
Mars or any other planet and then of
course back here on earth as our planet
is facing a climate crisis as our
climate could be unlivable in our
children or grandchildren 's lifetime i
believe we need a strong symbol a flag
to unite us to fight not just as nations
but as a speech
thank you
[Applause]